[Music]
it has been two years since geralt of
rivia has found cyrilla the lion cup of
syndra in the forest around sudden a
both a long way in season one until
destiny brought them together however
even more exciting than the stories up
to the meeting will be those that will
follow in the witcher season 2. for soon
the time will come and geralt and siri
will begin their journey together but
what has actually happened up to this
point this is a question that can indeed
be asked two years after their first
season premiere especially when you
consider how many different time periods
the last season took place in in order
to save you hours of research on the
internet we have summarized the key
facts for you in this video in addition
we'll give you a small preview of what
we can expect in the second season
keeping it as spoiler-free as possible
admittedly the first season was
certainly confusing for many witcher
newcomers so that you may have seen it
two or three times at best that's why we
decided to reconstruct the story
chronologically long before siri was
born in 1206 the then 14 year old
yennefer of vangenberg was brought to
aratusa by the sorceress tisaya to begin
her training in magic for four years she
had to endure much until she was finally
transferred to the court of the king of
edin after her transformation 21 years
later this is where witcher geralt of
rivia walks on the stage in the city of
blavik and he meets the young renfree
who's supposed to be a woman of lilith
therefore the wizard's dragonborn
requests geralt's help to kill her for
him the witcher refuses it first however
since renfree cannot refrain from
hunting the wizard geralt gets in her
way and kills her shortly before her
death she reveals the witch's fate by
telling him that a girl in the forest is
his destiny as a result of the fight
geralt is given his legendary title the
butcher of blavican
he spends 9 years wandering the world
with his bad reputation until he meets
the bar dandelion in a dirty tavern the
latter promises to restore his
reputation he joins him to hunt down and
kill a local devil in the end though
they are captured by villavendrell the
king of the elves with some luck they
are able to talk their way out of the
situation and this is how the song toss
a coin to your witcher came into being
another nine years go by until dandelion
asked geralt for favor he's asked to
accompany him to the court of syndra the
wedding ceremony of pavetta the daughter
of queen salanthi is taking place the
bard is sadly not safe there as he has
already gotten lost in some of the
highborne's bedrooms and many kings want
to see him death so geralt goes along
with him as his personal bodyguard
during the ceremony things go awry when
the night of dooney of the all the
forest enters the hall and by the law of
surprise demands pavetta to be his
consort years ago he saved her father's
life in a battle and the latter promised
him whatever he had left at home without
knowing or expecting him after a long
struggle in the great hall celenti tries
to slay him with her own hands until
pabetta herself intervenes and shows her
magical powers not knowing of her power
not being able to control it she is
about to destroy everything until geralt
manages to stop her ultimately celanthy
agrees to doonie's request and the
latter promises geralt a favor the
witcher without thinking twice asks for
the same thing as the knight himself the
law of surprise he does not realize that
this will make cirelia his destiny since
the princess is already pregnant with
her seven long years pass before geralt
and jennifer finally cross paths
jennifer is tasked with helping him
remove a genie from dandelion she
accepts albede with the ulterior motive
of using him to finally be able to have
children in the end both barely escape
death and develop feelings for each
other
however it will take them 5 years to see
each other again both are hired to hunt
the dragon in spite of the fact that
these creatures are considered extinct
eventually they protect the last golden
dragon but part ways in the final
quarrel following the confrontation with
yen carol sets off for sintra to claim
his child of providence once there
however celanthy is unwilling to hand
over celia to him having raised the
young princess after her parents died in
a shipwreck she tries to outsmart geralt
by giving him a different child and he
finds out he is imprisoned by the queen
the queen is cautioned that she will
bring great disaster upon her kingdom if
she goes against providence but she
ignores the warnings of all her advisors
shortly thereafter syndra is attacked
and overrun by nilfgaard in the massacre
of syndra nearly everyone in the city is
slain with only a few able to escape
including the witcher and siri dying
celanthy informs her granddaughter of
her fate and instructs her to find
geralt of rivia as she flees she
discovers to have the same powers as her
mother while siri now tries to get as
far away from sintra as possible geralt
chases after her concerned by the
growing force of the nilfgaardian empire
group of wizards sets out to stop the
advancing army among them yennefer at
the battle of sodom they attempt to halt
the advance until the northern kingdoms
can unite their armies against nilfgaard
in the process nearly all the wizards
are killed not far from the scene of the
battle siri has been taken in by peasant
family while geralt in turn travels with
the family's father once arrived at the
farm he runs into the forest where he at
last finds his child of surprise
of all the heroes that appeared to us in
the first season only four remain in
season two fortunately nothing has
changed regarding the cast so we can
still see henry cavill as geralt freya
allen siri anya kalotra as jennifer and
joey bate as dandelion yet there will be
some visual changes as we've already
seen in the trailer and from set
pictures the producers are addressing
the criticism of some fans who felt that
the armor in the series was too plain
and there was more splendid in the video
games so not only will geralt be given a
makeover but the troops of nilfgaard
also will receive brand new equipment
there will be one change on this end
however our hearts are bleeding but
geralt's faithful companion mount roach
will most likely be played by a new
horse in season two at least that's what
the pictures we have seen so far from
the set suggest
vasamir is certainly eagerly awaited
after his animated film geralt's
instructor and mentor is finally making
his big appearance in the live action
series the old witcher is played by
cambodia still he's not the only famous
character from cameron that we know from
the books and the video game the witcher
ashkel cohen and lambert will also get a
part many fans of the books are probably
looking forward to novellum the cursed
man from a grain of truth a short story
in the geralt saga exciting for the plot
beyond the old keep will truly be the
role of queen meth queen mev is the
warrior queen of rivia and larian plays
a significant role in the second of
guardian war moreover we will also see a
couple of minor parts from the first
season return in the eight episodes we
are already looking forward to tessaya
villavendral velga ford's dragonborn
friend gilla and istred
since the books are done some of the
storyline can already be deduced without
spoiling much we will just cover the
basics so you can get an idea of the
plot season 2 will begin right after the
battle of sudden when geralt finds the
graves of the deceased wizards in search
of yennefer as you can probably figure
hers is not among them she was captured
by frankie and the surviving forces of
nilfgaard he heads off to kirmoren with
siri as he believes she will only be
safe there she will begin her training
with visamir while geralt himself goes
on a monster hunt again a separate
storyline will also be given to jennifer
in siri jennifer who is unable to bear
children due to the ceremony develops
maternal feelings for the lion cup and
henceforth begins to protect her like
geralt besides the politics in the
country will be playing a role as well
as seen at the end of season 1 the
northern kingdoms have allied against
nilfgaard and santa army to sodom this
leads to a very fragile truce it lasts
exactly four years until the beginning
of the second of guardian war as you can
see a longer span of time will be
covered again unlike season 1 however
the story will be told chronologically
this time for those who want to read the
books first the stories that will
adapted in season 2 are from blood of
elves a grain of truth a shard of ice
and season of storms
alright now you are well prepared for
the second season of the witcher on
friday december 17th the season will
finally start which character are you
looking forward to the most maybe you
already know some monsters from the
books of the video games that you would
like to see in the second season let us
know in the comments see you next time
[Music]
you